hey youtubers is charlie so earlier this
week there was this anonymous person
blasting warner brothers claiming they
used to work at the studio talking
specifically a lot about the Wonder
Woman movie so there's gonna be
breakdown of what's going on and why
that's all bullcrap so you may have
heard that someone was blasting Warner
Brothers and saying there was a big you
know big mess in general with all their
films behind the scenes they were
particularly singling out Wonder Woman
because that's like the upcoming DC
movie but from the things that it talks
about and the things that it leaves out
it sounds like this was like a
relatively low-level person like an
intern working for someone who was way
down on the totem pole because they
really don't get into specifics when
they talk about some of the problems
behind the scenes they don't even
mention Geoff Johns once so they don't
talk about any of the things that have
changed as a result of the
dissatisfaction that people have
expressed with some of the previous DC
films this year so the only one in any
official capacity you know from the
other side of the firing line that has
said anything about this or reacted to
it is patty Jenkins the director of the
Wonder Woman movie who is like you know
who acts kind of like you woke her up in
the middle of the night like wait what
what the hell is going on this is
get out of here so just to
clarify what's going on with the Wonder
Woman movie and what's going on behind
the scenes at Warner Brothers now so
Wonder Woman right now is still in like
work print form like everything that
they've shot is all crammed together in
one massive edit so it's like four and a
half hours long they have to cut it down
to what will eventually be the
theatrical run that's just like a long
process it takes a long time to cut that
down there'll be a bunch of different
cuts of the film as they test it with
audiences it's the same thing with every
single film in the history of filmmaking
so like a lot of the stuff that was said
about the film being a mess doesn't
really address that it just says the
film is a mess well you know all films
are messes until an editor comes in and
works their magic and turns it into
something that you or I might go see in
a movie theater that makes sense so the
Wonder Woman movie I think is going to
go a long way to address a lot of the
complaints that people who have been
dissatisfied with DC movies whether or
not you've liked the last couple of DC
movies Wonder Woman is like a shift in
tone for the film's just because the
Wonder Woman character comes from a very
different place than Batman Batman is a
very dark character one woman has a lot
of dark things going on
her life but she's kind of like this
symbol of hope so you know that's why
it's very easy for them to do the film
during World War 1 because there's
people dying everywhere the earth has
been torn up with trench warfare just
everything is a complete mess so she
steps in to try and fix everything so
that you know you're going to get that
general sense from the tone of the film
to she'll have a very calming presence
on all the angry bros so that'll be
happening in like a metaphorical way
with the fandom in a literal way in the
context of the film so it feels like
this big fan letter that everyone's been
talking about is really just that it's
like a fan who was like an intern or
like a low-level grunt at Warner
Brothers who is dissatisfied with the
previous films and is just trying to
vent their frustrations without really
having any general knowledge of what's
actually going on so in general I would
just treat this like the crying baby on
the airplane that you're just forced to
sit next to for like the next half hour
you just like put your headphones in
just ignore it it's just complete
so what's going to happen in
the next couple of months is you will
continue to see new Wonder Woman
trailers because Wonder Woman's not
coming till next summer so there'll be
plenty more marketing in the spring to
you know typically when they get within
a couple months of a movie coming out
that's when they really start marketing
films so that's still a long ways off by
that time they'll have a much stronger
cut of the film you'll start hearing a
lot more about it as well as the other
films that will follow like Justice
League like typically when studios are
really afraid of films they won't let
journalists anywhere near they want to
advance screenings they'll embargo
certain types of coverage for a film
until after its release so just to show
how confident they are in the stuff
that's coming Warner Brothers had
journalists to the set of Justice League
and they watched a scene get filmed
months before comic-con happened in part
of the scene that they got to see was
what ended up in that Justice League
trailer from comic-con so I'll put a
link to that at the end of this but
they're just so confident in the stuff
that they're working on that they gave
you the work print version of the
trailer like it's not super polished
like a normal trailer would be it's just
like here's the footage that we shot we
kind of cut this together in a really
quick way it's just a taste for what is
coming in relay I think like the big
purpose of that was just to let you know
what the tone of the film is going to be
the characters are starting to feel more
like the characters that you remember
from the comics which I've you know feel
like was one of the big complaints
against Batman V Superman was that even
though Batman felt like an amazing
version of Batman Superman did not feel
like Superman so just like a little
course correction on some of the more
hopeful characters in the DC Universe
and based on this it seems like that's
what's happened I mean obviously we
haven't seen Superman back yet because
officially they're still trying to keep
that mystery up of you know what his
status is but they basically said that
he's part of the Justice League in the
comics of course he's going to come back
and Justice League at some point but
hopefully that clears up why people have
been blasting Warner Brothers you know
because of this anonymous letter fit you
know very circumspect so I would just
treat it like gossip you can
totally ignore I don't worry about it
they still have a long time before
Wonder Woman is actually going to be
finished before it's going to be the
film that you will see in theaters as
well as justice like they're still
filming justice league right now and
remember that when they're editing films
there will typically be three or four
different cuts of a film at least
especially the really big films that
they'll test with different audiences
just to see how people react to certain
parts of the film like when they were
making guardians of the galaxy they said
there was even like a cut of the film
that didn't have any jokes in it if you
can imagine that like a weird cut of
guardians of the galaxy that was
supposed to be very not funny so like if
somebody saw that cut of the film and
then said oh my god guardians of the
galaxy is a complete mess there's no
jokes in it that you would have any
understanding of what the final film
look like which wound up being one of
the most funny Marvel films that's been
made so far so you couldn't tell I'm
very excited about Wonder Woman there's
going to be another trailer but it
probably won't drop for at least another
month or two so in the meantime there is
a new round of the giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video it's just
a twenty dollar amazon gift card
there'll be a bunch of DC bunch of
Marvel next week and they're supposed to
be a walking dead preview tonight so if
they talk about anything interesting I
will totally do a Walking Dead video on
Monday or you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
watch that Wonder Woman trailer again
and you can click here to watch the
Justice League trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight